un but qui fait mal jusqu'à cette
fameuse 85e minute les verts de trappes
mené 1-0 contre plutôt en match en
retard du championnat de régionale 4 un
avantage acquis rapidement sur la
première action du match suite à cette
récupération les trappistes ont ensuite
reculé en seconde période avant de se
faire égaliser pense y attendais pas on
a ouvert le score très tôt apprécié et
très difficile de savoir gérer un
une ouverture de score très rapidement
comme ça on l'a plutôt bien fait
malheureusement sur les dix dernières
minutes on traque parce qu'on a trop
vouloir chercher ce deuxième on va
priver de l'égalisation dans cette
rencontre et n'a pas réussi à se mettre
à l'abri rapidement malgré deux
occasions nettes en première période
un manque de réalisme récurrent pour
cette équipe qui n'a marqué que 18 buts
en 14 matches de championnat aura manqué
de bonnes raisons le but c'est
effectivement puis à la cathédrale a
surtout manqué de finition en feutre
vraiment fait enfin quoi dans les gestes
quotidiens l'appliquer comme ça arrive
sur plusieurs joueurs différents donc la
première fois le premier joueur y doute
la deuxième fois le deuxième joueur
doutera la troisième fois le troisième
joueur de tra et ainsi de suite et et sa
patronne lui notre secteur offensif en
confiance mais dans la foulée en
on va pas se chercher des excuses il ya
des jours où justement on va pas du tout
marquer on a eu la chance d'en mettre un
malheureusement on n'a pas été ce
costaud pour préserver ce score là un
manque de réalisme qu'il faudra corriger
dès ce dimanche 4 mars en match en
retard contre goussainville
avant cette rencontre à pointe à la 11e
place du championnat